it's 25 on your wednesday morning do not
get used to having eastern back open
under the 95 515 yeah that 10-day
closure of eastern was scheduled to wrap
up late tonight but by the way breaking
news it is open right now but seriously
the nevada department of
transportation's i515 project.com
website says
they're shutting it down again for six
days starting on monday the 25th and at
the same time they're also going to
close desert inn again under the freeway
between boulder highway and flamingo
both closures they are for bridge
demolition replacements that are just
part of the overall freeway fix up
project now the 95 515 itself will be
open in both work areas while the
streets underneath are shut down
although there will be lane restrictions
so if these parts of the freeway are
part of your regular commuting habits i
cannot urge you enough to either keep
checking that i-515 project website or
sign up for email or text alerts just
ask the folks at ndot sometimes it's
hard to keep up with constantly changing
work schedules we've got the links to
the projects as well as all of our
driving you crazy stories when you go to
our webpage eightnewsnow.com click
traffic then driving you crazy buckle up
drive carefully and please put down that
phone something's driving you crazy
email me traffic eight at eight news now
dot com